[Música]
el presidente estadounidense Joe biden
indultará las penas a todos los
condenados a nivel Federal por posesión
de marihuana se calcula que más de 7000
personas podrían beneficiarse de la
medida el anuncio se da pocas semanas de
unas elecciones de medio término en las
que los demócratas podrían perder sus
mayorías legislativas
el presidente peruano Pedro Castillo se
reunió con el secretario de estado de
Estados Unidos Anthony bunsen en el
marco de una segunda jornada de la
asamblea general de la Organización de
Estados Americanos además al mandatario
peruano se le prohibió nuevamente salir
del país Tenemos reporte desde Lima
Haití pide ayuda internacional debido a
una crisis que se agudiza cada vez más
grupos criminales controlan la terminal
de combustible de Puerto Príncipe en
medio de una escasez que ha complicado
la atención médica y el abastecimiento
de productos básicos a lo que se suma un
brote de cólera que deja 8 personas
muertas
Hola Bienvenidos a las noticias de
América en frases 24 los saluda Andrés
Meza Muñoz empezamos en Estados Unidos
porque la Casa Blanca anunció que el
presidente Joe biden perdonará la pena a
todos los condenados a nivel Federal por
posesión de marihuana se calcula que más
de 7.000 personas podrían beneficiarse
de la medida sin embargo el indulto no
cubre las condenas por posesión de otras
drogas o por cargos relacionados con la
producción o posesión de marihuana con
la intención de distribuirla tampoco
Aplica para los ciudadanos que se
encontraban en Estados Unidos sin
estatus legal en el momento de su
arresto previamente hablamos con Erick
Fajardo profesor e investigador
universitario y también consultor
político y especialista en análisis de
conflictos quien nos contó Qué significa
esta medida de Cara a las elecciones de
medio término y en las que los
demócratas podrían perder sus mayorías
legislativas
bien es parte de una batería de medidas
y además de legislaciones que el
presidente ha ido tomando enfocándose en
grupos que yo pienso que a los
demócratas consideran que son todavía
gananciables en el marco de la
acumulación de apoyo electoral esta ha
sido una elección muy complicada para el
partido demócrata ha empezado con una
fuerte factura de apoyo que han perdido
debido a la guerra y a las consecuencias
económicas sobre el precio de los
commodities la subida del alza los
carburantes les pasó en marzo a mayo una
fuerte factura Y hoy día después de una
recuperación paulatina creo que se ve en
forzados ante la nueva crecida del costo
de los combustibles ante los nuevos
efectos de las medidas fijadas por la
OPEP a improvisar algunas medidas que
tienden yo creo que a tocar sectores
electorales que los cuales el voto
demócrata se concentra en este caso la
población afroamericana el mismo
presidente va a ir en ha declarado que
esta medida es sin duda una medida para
beneficiar a gente como Blanca lo ha
dicho hoy día y creo que ese es el
enfoque electoral que le están dando a
esta aprobación en México al menos 20
personas murieron asesinadas en un doble
ataque armado en el Estado de Guerrero
entre los que se encontraba el alcalde
Conrado Mendoza y varios funcionarios
más Marta Moya nos trae más detalles en
el siguiente informe una de las masacres
más mortíferas en lo que va de año en
México las autoridades federales
anunciaron este jueves que la matanza en
el Estado de Guerrero de la víspera
atribuida Al enfrentamiento entre
integrantes de dos grupos del crimen
organizado Ya deja varias decenas de
Muertos entre ellos el regidor municipal
de San Miguel totolapan el pueblo
epicentro del ataque la gobernadora del
Estado condenó lo ocurrido Con promesas
de cero impunidad Lamento profundamente
el sensible fallecimiento del alcalde de
San Miguel totolapan Conrado Mendoza
almeda condenó los hechos y reitero que
en la gobernación de Guerrero no habrá
impunidad ante la artera agresión contra
el presidente municipal y funcionarios
del ayuntamiento
la sangre presuntamente llevada a cabo
por las disputas entre la familia
michoacana y Los Tequileros dos
facciones criminales que operan en el
estado conmocionó al país y también
provocó el rechazo del presidente
mexicano el caso
de
son organizaciones
que vienen de tiempo atrás
no surgieron En este gobierno
y Estamos buscando atender las causas
desde el partido Revolución democrática
formación a la que pertenecía el alcalde
asesinado en la balacera pidieron
responsabilidades la dirección nacional
ejecutiva del PRD se suma al llamado del
periodismo guerrerense en Solidaridad
con las familias de totolapan Guerrero y
exige la renuncia del gabinete de
seguridad así como la investigación y
Castigo a los responsables del multi
homicidio durante el mandato de López
Obrador se han reportado 60 decesos de
representantes públicos según la agencia
etelec una tendencia violenta que se
mantiene al alza a todas las escalas en
el país en Perú se llevó a cabo la
segunda jornada de la asamblea general
de la Organización de Estados Americanos
y te vas como la democracia y los
derechos humanos fueron foco del debate
24 países aprobaron una declaración de
repudio contra Rusia por la guerra en
Ucrania sin embargo Brasil México y
Argentina nos suscribieron antes los
países miembros apoyaron el proyecto de
paz total en Colombia que propone el
gobierno de Gustavo Petro y el
secretario de estado de Estados Unidos
Antonio blinken advirtió sobre la
proliferación de líderes
antidemocráticos en el Continente aunque
no mencionó ningún hombre el funcionario
también se refirió a la situación
migratoria de las Américas y anunció una
nueva ayuda humanitaria para migrantes y
refugiados
y en el marco de este evento de la olla
en Lima se reunieron el presidente Pedro
castillo y el secretario de estado de
Estados Unidos Anthony blinquen quien
termina de esta manera su gira por
América del Sur los detalles del
encuentro con nuestro corresponsal
Francisco Zacarías
muy buenas noches desde Lima en la cita
entre el presidente Pedro castillo y el
secretario de estado de los Estados
Unidos ante un linken se trataron temas
como los desafíos en la lucha contra el
narcotráfico el políticas de apoyo para
cerrar la brecha sociales y también la
migración de ciudadanos venezolanos a la
cual el secretario estadounidense Se
comprometió a seguir el colaborando en
una rueda de prensa que se realizó luego
de esta reunión el Anthony blinken
señaló que la agresión de Rusia Ucrania
ha generado una serie de efectos
colaterales como es en la subida del
precio de los combustibles la crisis de
los alimentos y los fertilizantes que
afectado a varias naciones entre ellas
de Perú y se ha comprometió a trabajar
junto al presidente Pedro Castillo para
hacer frente a estos desafíos en otra
parte Anthony blinken señaló que Estados
Unidos está estudiando una serie de
opciones en respuesta a sus relaciones
con Arabia Saudita luego de que algunos
países de la OPEP que incluye a Rusia
acordaron reducir la producción de
petróleo en otras noticias de Perú El
Congreso negó nuevamente al presidente
Castillo un permiso para salir del país
esta vez para viajar primero a Bruselas
donde tenía previsto reunirse con
autoridades de la Unión Europea y luego
al Vaticano donde tenía previsto
encontrarse con el Papa Francisco los
legisladores justificaron su decisión en
las seis carpetas de investigación que
siguen abiertas contra el mandatario en
agosto ya se le había negado el permiso
para viajar a Bogotá para la posesión
del presidente colombiano Gustavo Petro
el canciller solicitó al legislativo
revisar la medida
y en Haití la situación no mejora la
crisis de combustibles ha empeorado la
atención médica y el abastecimiento de
productos básicos en medio de un brote
de cólera que ya ha dejado 8 muertos
motivo por el que el Primer Ministro
Ariel Henry pidió ayuda a la comunidad
internacional Alba Santana con los
detalles
el jueves en los recientes de Puerto
Príncipe en la capital haitiana se
despertaron
óricamente desiertas y con la terminal
de combustible de la ciudad bajo el
control de las pandillas ilegales una
situación de desgobierno que junto a la
crisis económica y de abastecimiento que
atraviesa el país el Primer Ministro
calificó como crisis humanitaria
internacional la pidió la comunidad
internacional y a todos los amigos de
Haití que nos apoyen que nos ayuden a
luchar contra esta crisis humanitaria
Necesito que nos den apoyo para evitar
que la gente muera en masa
no obstante muchos haitianos piensan que
la raíz del problema está en el propio
Angie con una Falta de confianza en el
gobierno en aumento desde el magnicidio
de jovenel Moisés en julio de 2021
lo que el pueblo pide y piensa es que
Ariel es un incapaz y no puede liderar
le están pidiendo que se vaya y ponga
una persona seria a gobernar el país
métete
y es que la falta de combustibles
investigado a reducir el personal de los
hospitales y ha impedido la distribución
de productos básicos todo en medio de un
brote de cólera registrado el domingo
que ya ha dejado varios muertos factores
que han llevado al descontento de la
población al límite con protestas desde
inicios de septiembre
lo que la gente esperaba es que Ariel
Henry hablara del tema de la gasolina
del alto coste de vida y de la
inseguridad
con la capital sumida en el caos varias
embajadas como la de española de Francia
han cerrado en el país mientras Naciones
Unidas ya expresado su preocupación por
los bloqueos en las gasolineras y la
falta de atención médica hasta que es
informativo Gracias por acompañarnos
[Música]